morning if you please rise and join me
for the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
justice for
all with that I am going to open the
public hearing on House Bill 11 197 and
invite the prime sponsor to introduce
the
bill
thank you Mr chairman and uh good
morning members of the committee thank
you all for the work that you do for the
record my name is Chris muns I am one of
the four Representatives representing
the town of Hampton in Rockingham
District 29 I'm here to introduce HB
1197 of which I am the prime sponsor the
title of the bill is an act relative to
criminal background checks
this is not about background checks for
purchasers of
firearms it is about taking some small
steps forward to hope hopefully expedite
the process employers who are required
by state law to obtain background checks
must follow before they are able to hire
certain
employees more specifically IT addresses
those situations where a federal
criminal history record information
record check is
required if you are like me any bill
that is 11 pages long can be a little
shall we say
overwhelming what I hope I can do in the
time you're granting me this morning is
try to dispel any concerns you might
have I worked with the Department of
Safety to craft this bill and they are
here to speak in support of it I also
reached out to all the affected state
agencies to ensure that they are aware
of it they do have some concerns about
funding which I appreciate and hope to
address um
today however none expressed any serious
reservations I hope that they will not
do so here today then again that's why
we have these
hearings let me break down the bill for
you it essentially has three parts Part
One included in section one of the bill
which extends from page one through the
first three lines of Page Three provides
information on the laws and processes
currently in place place and the
challenges they create as it relates to
National record
checks part two which is the Lion Share
of the bill consisting of sections 2
through 23 starting on page three line
four and continuing through line through
page 9 line 31 of the bill identify
specific changes in statute recommended
by the department of safety to permit
additional state agencies to assist them
with the process of collecting
fingerprints
part three included in section 24 of the
bill starting on page 9 line 32 through
Page 11 line three establishes a multi-
agency task force to conduct a review of
all employment volunteer positions
referenced in statute where an FBI
record check is currently required
recommend whether such record checks
will continue to be required identify
any new positions where a record check
is currently not required but where it
should be and identify other specific
steps and recommendations that should be
taken to ensure that employment related
record checks are processed as
expeditiously as possible this task
force would also identify specific
funding
requirements there are many positions
where New Hampshire Law requires
employees Andor volunteers must pass a
record
check those positions fall under the
purview of the following state agencies
education banking health and human
services safety Revenue Administration
the office of professional Li Insurance
certification and the lottery and
charitable gaming commission there are
also numerous Municipal and County
positions that require a record check
these record checks are required by
state law to protect the public however
we are facing a Workforce crisis and it
has become increasingly difficult to
fill in a timely manner many of the
positions where these record checks are
required candidates for a position are
accepting other positions before the
record checks can be completed and the
turnaround time on requests for
volunteers often results in activities
or events being understaffed or
delayed a national record check request
must be submitted to the to the FBI and
the FBI requires that all requests
submitted to it must be processed and
transmitted by authorized law
enforcement
agencies all requests submitted to the
FBI must include a release form signed
by the applicant that includes
demographic data about them and a
complete set of
fingerprints under current state statute
fingerprints must be taken by a
qualified law enforcement agency for
example your local police department or
an authorized employee of the Department
of
Safety that creates an inevitable Log
Jam the only exceptions are rs a 1891
13-1 which provides an authorized
employee of a school administrative Unit
School District chartered public school
or public Academy who can also take a
complete set of fingerprints and RSA 361
A2 which gives that same authority to an
authorized employee of the banking
Department part two of the bill sections
2 through 23 of this bill uh what what
what part two section 2 through 23 of
this Bill does is extend the authority
to take a complete set of fingerprints
to other state agencies and departments
with oversight for other employees and
volunteers where a record check is
required these are quick fixes that will
significantly increase the number of
individuals and locations authorized to
complete to collect complete set of
fingerprints and address at least one
Log Jam contributing to the time it
takes to obtain a national record check
the bill does not change the number of
positions where a record check is
required or the requirement that
agencies will still need to forward the
fingerprints and accompanying
documentation to the criminal records
unit within the department of safety for
their review and transmittal to the FBI
or the ways that they transmit that
information those are much those are
more complex questions that deserve more
and careful study what part three
section 24 of the bill does is establish
a multi- agency task force to examine
these and other issues the task force
will be shared by the commissioner of
the Department of Safety and consists of
representatives from the following
agencies education Revenue
Administration health and human services
the office of professional Li insur and
certification and the lottery and gaming
commission the task force is also
encouraged to consult with interested
stakeholders such as the new New
Hampshire Municipal Association New
Hampshire Association of counties and
the new hampsh the New Hampshire banking
department and the New Hampshire school
administrators Association the task
force will present its initial findings
onor before November 1st
2024 so that if there are any
expenditures required to implement any
of those findings there is an
opportunity to include them in the next
bien anum's budget Andor an opportunity
to any required introduce any required
legislation for the 2025 session the
task force the task force final report
will be required honor before September
1st
2025 when I first began to explore this
issue I thought how hard can it be to
reduce the turnaround time all we need
to do is scan the fingerprints set up a
website push a button send the request
in and receive a yes no answer back
within minutes if not
seconds well with the help of my friends
at the department of safety I learned it
is not that simple and shame on me for
thinking that anything could be that
simple after talking with
representatives from the criminal record
unit and the and assistant commissioner
Edwards I am convinced they understand
how important it is to quickly and
accurately obtain criminal record checks
and they understand the need to be able
to hire people quickly My Hope Is that
HB 1197 will offer them some quick fix
additional tools to make that happen
while at the same time pulling together
representatives of other state agencies
who are most invested in this process to
investigate other longer term solutions
to ensure that happens I hope you will
recommend this bill as ought to pass
thank you for your time this morning and
I will be happy to try to answer your
questions the key word being try thank
you thank you
representative the
um so just to to distill it down what
your bill does is it attempts
to speed up the record check process
process it doesn't change who needs to
have their record checks it just deals
with the process of getting the record
checks is that correct that's correct
okay further questions representative s
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um you referenced costs in this
but I don't see a financial note and I
wasn't sure if I missed
something um yeah that was a an issue
that came up this morning when I was
talking with um some um representatives
of state agencies um um I I don't I
don't know why there was no fi fiscal
note I mean the only reason I I I'm I'm
I'm guessing is that um because of the
way that I structured it so that there
was the task force that would be making
recommendations about what the cost
would be um going forward but I I I
don't know why there was no fiscal note
attached the the the the the cost there
were there will certainly be some costs
and when when people from the uh
Department of Safety come to testify you
might want to ask them um there may be
there will be some costs for per perhaps
for additional um Scanning
Machines um and um you know potentially
some Personnel costs um but uh to answer
your question I don't know why there was
no fiscal
note represent
Muse yes thanks for taking my question
help me understand why um there are some
changes in your bill that would take
place immediately with passage of the
bill but there are others that are
deferred uh until uh a task force can be
assembled and make recommendations um uh
I'm just curious about your rationale
for doing
that um well I what I wanted to do was
you know get the get get I guess address
the policy issue of whether or not other
state agencies should should be
empowered to be able to to collect um
fingerprints um so that the department
of safety then kind of knew the universe
that they were working with um and that
and that that could then they could then
work with the those agencies to kind of
figure out exactly what infrastructure
would would be needed to support that um
I had some conversations with uh people
this morning uh along those same lines
and there was a suggestion that perhaps
the effective date for the bill could be
pushed out a little bit um but it was
really just to try to get them get the
ball rolling so that we and and give the
department the statutory Authority that
they need to start you know figuring out
what the new infrastructure should look
like see no further questions thank you
for introducing your bill thank you very
much
uh the chair calls uh Victor muzy from
the state
please morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you for having me
this morning uh my name is Victor Muzzy
I'm a captain with the New Hampshire
State Police in charge of the Justice
information Bureau and I'm here to
represent the department of safety uh on
this bill and I'd like to thank
representative Ms for working together
head of uh submitting this to make sure
that there was a mutual understanding of
what what needed what was needed to help
us certainly but I think to answer um
what I heard to be sort of the initial
question is um as he spoke um the record
check process for education has already
been identified so it allows an
authorized employee of the Department of
Education to fingerprint folks for us
and so many of these many other rsas at
the moment don't do that so it sort of
ties our Collective hand as as law
enforcement being the only folks that
can fingerprint for for these other
various entities and agencies and so
aligning all of these statutes certainly
opens up that window for us to be able
to do that um and allow some of these
other state agencies to be able to
capture fingerprints for us much like
Department of Education is doing in the
superintendent offices and things and so
that was one idea that we had brought uh
up in the in the confines of the
conversation to help address um some of
the the backlog or some of the issues
and so um right now to date we've got I
think 75 aphis machines which are the
electronic machines that we capture
fingerprints on placed strategically as
best we can throughout the state and
we've got another 10 more of those
coming um that we will Implement here
very shortly as soon as we can we can
accept uh some grant money that we have
will use to to purchase those with and
as we have historically done and so uh
the intent here um in concert with this
bill would be to provide some of these
machines uh to those agencies willing um
in the future uh that could fingerprint
their folks for us as as part of that
process and there's been some interest
with some agencies and I suspect more
interest once we get these the rsas
cleaned up to to more to better align uh
with that to be able to actually have
them capturing the fingerprints for us
and so uh that was one area where um
historically I'll say since 2020 I think
let's call 2020 the year that that
caught up with us and there was several
things that happened outside of Co but
really related to covid that caused a
backlog for us and and uh the governor
had issued an order obviously um
allowing folks to work without being
fingerprinted and things and when that
order was lifted we saw a huge influx
and um an overwhelming workload that we
have since completely cleared up and I'm
I'm hap happy to say here today that um
we've got five available fingerprint
appointments in conquered and I think 21
tomorrow or something thereabouts and so
obtaining a fingerprint appointment at
the moment is not an issue um and and
coupled with that the turnaround time
for providing record checks for agencies
that are doing a background check is
done within a week from our perspective
the department of safety's perspective
so the backlog is is for all intents and
purposes cleared up is non-existent it
does does not exist anymore however in
the interest of
um expanding upon that I I think these
this this bill here to align these rsas
um respective to that of education is is
the right thing to do so we can continue
to expand that that allowance I should
say to to capture um fingerprints and so
um again I just wanted to point out that
we we no longer have the backlog that we
had we've worked through that but
obviously it takes some time to catch up
from that and and the the the education
I guess to to understand that that's
that's no longer really a problem for us
doesn't mean it won't happen again we
certainly have busier times of the year
than other times back to school and
other other things that are happening
College graduations and and whatnot that
seem to contribute to that but nothing
like we saw in
2020 um
and so you know we obviously will work
very closely the commission I think will
work very closely with um on determining
what needs to be done I think
collectively we probably should look at
what background checks are we conducting
certainly the department of safety has
no
um I don't want to say interest we have
an interest in it but we have no say I
guess it's up to these other agencies
state agencies on whether or not they
want to do background checks we we
certainly are there to provide that
service but don't really have an opinion
I suppose on on whether or not it's
appropriate but certainly would love to
be part of the conversation so it
probably is time to look at you know are
there other positions that should be
checked um are there some that we're
doing now that we don't need to do so
this is a great time to look at that
process overall and see if we can uh
make any efficiencies there on a on a
state level
um I think there was one other thing
that I was going to say but it escapes
my mind at the moment so thank you for
my uh hearing my testimony and I'll be
happy to take any questions thank you is
it your understanding that the the this
bill will enable you to um enter into
agreements with various agencies to
place aphis machines in their locations
is that and then authorize them to
process those is that what I'm
understanding I think that's the intent
I don't know that the changing the
RSA speaks to theou that we would have
to have but it certainly will allow us
to physically put the machine there and
have authorized you know employees of
that agency fingerprint for us uh the
mou I guess I would see that as sort of
a
separate
distinct process that we would probably
have to enter into as we've we've done
in other
instances since you already have an are
continuing to put these um machines
spread out throughout the state is it
necessary to then put them in specific
agencies like that I mean I could see
maybe oplc because they're constantly
but a school district does that make
sense I'm not really sure I understand
how that would work yeah we've had a
couple of school districts that have
actually done that and the way it's I
can think of one in particular um where
the the aphis machine it's a portable
machine that the the police department
actually houses I guess but where it's
portable they they bring it to the
school to be able to use it for that
purpose too and so they've sort of
collaborate collaborated within that
that town or that District to be able to
do that and
so is there a need not at the moment I
guess um I think it's more of a
convenience factor what we've heard from
some agencies is that some of their
clientele have to travel great distances
and other things so you know obviously
most of these machines for state
agencies would likely be in conquered
which again is is probably not
convenient for some of the population
anyways but it's just another option
really um and before I forget the other
thing to mention is we have been I guess
graced with the ability to purchase Liv
scan machines through grant money
they're about $20,000 a piece what
doesn't um what we we don't have any
funding for other than than budgeted
funding is the maintenance for those
machines and so um relative to to the
costs right out of the gate I can say
the more of these machines we buy the
more maintenance we're going to have to
pay on them and we've we've yet to be
able to find a funding source uh outside
of our our budget to be able to pay for
that and maintenance I think on per
machine is about
3500 a year um and an additional $200 if
there's a
printer does Nick's money cover that
could it be used for towards that Nick's
grants uh no no no we historically have
bought the machines with uh nship um
money which is the national criminal
history Improvement project I believe is
what that stands for okay I envisioned
the machines that they have for example
at silencer Co if you want to go buy a
suppressor um you take they take your
prints right there instantly to the FBI
and um you quickly get a yay or nay is
yeah I don't I'm not familiar with that
Arrangement but it it's well it's part
of the instant background check system
but this is different than the instant
background check system correct this is
the records you get for an employment
check are not the same for the instant
background check you just get a proceed
or do not proceed right versus this you
get the actual list of the offenses
correct okay thank depending upon the
agency and and what they're authorized
to see exactly yes sir okay um
representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman that this may have been
addressed and I apologize if it was so
my understanding is you know you can
have you can have somebody that has had
their fingerprints taken you know say to
work at a school and you know maybe they
go get a job as a bank um as a teller
would would this make it where if the
person has already had their information
captured that they don't have to keep on
redoing it to you know maybe pull from a
central location or no no every check is
done independently for the purpose that
it's needed so if they switch
professions it's a it's a brand new
check and the other thing that gets
cautioned is stale records so if you
were fingerprinted yesterday and your
record is released today tomorrow your
record could be different in theory so
okay it it doesn't really transpire time
okay um thank you thank you for my
followup this may be something you're
not sure of there was a there was a
study committee for the centralization
for fingerprints for background checks
do you think that is something maybe I I
know I was on it and we've never had a
meeting on it you think that's something
I should try to maybe pursue a little
bit more or would it not affect this at
all make it life easier for everybody
don't know that it would affect this at
all I guess so okay thank you you're
welcome represent here
G thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um on page two when
it lists the seven uh departments are
these departments are the Departments
you would like to have that privilege of
doing background
checks these are the Departments that I
would like to have
the potential of having a machine to
take fingerprints should they choose to
I guess or have the Manpower I
mean sure all right are the only one
that's doing it now is the education
department is that correct correct okay
all right thank
you so from a from a cost perspective
your assumption would be that the
agencies who receive these machines
would use them
essentially would train Uh current
Personnel correct in their use so it
wouldn't involve actually hiring any
people I don't believe so unless those
agencies would have a need to hire
additional resources to be able to do
that I can't speak to that but I think
the intent at least my thought would be
that yes they'd have pre-existing
employees that would be trained and
would be able to to do that and one
more and uh a little bit of of a
different question
um the the fact that these one thing I'm
trying to understand is is is there
because more people will be responsible
for for fingerprinting is is there more
potential uh for these records to be uh
mishandled in some way or made public in
in a way that we wouldn't want yep no
great question so currently and I'm
probably getting into the weeds here a
little bit too much but I'll give you
the background anyhow um as far as law
enforcement agencies go the the
interface I'll call it to to Department
of Safety is a two-way interface so in
other words um a law enforcement officer
takes a set of fingerprints um on their
machine and within 10 or 15 minutes they
actually get an initial response from
the FBI which includes some of that
person's criminal record um and that's
done so that the FBI doesn't care what
your name and date of birth is they care
what your fingerprints look like and
that's how they identify everybody so um
I've put in a name that I associated
with those fingerprints and it gets you
know sent to the FBI and often times you
know people lie when they get arrested
about who who they are and things like
that and so that information is provided
back to that machine in in the form of a
message um if you will so that I guess
that department or that that officer can
can see that okay I have the correct
person here and a little bit about their
criminal record and things like that
relative to bail and and things like
that so the intent and the idea here
would be the configuration for these
machines uh that are that at these
agencies would be one way so they would
only be submitting fingerprints to us uh
that a safety criminal records unit um
and not receiving any return information
from the FBI and so there would not be
that chance in that capacity or in that
venue for them to mishandle anything or
have even have access to to any
information on the machine um so they'd
be configured slightly differently I
guess than the law enforcement agency's
configuration to follow on to that
question using the machine is even
better because there's no physical
record there's no fingerprint card that
can be copy or anything like that
correct it's just all sent out and gone
yeah and the theory with you know the
old Inked fingerprint cards as they say
is um a you've got ink which is messy
and you're dealing with a piece of paper
and things um and and the aphis machines
are pretty intuitive I guess and
obviously capture a picture of your
fingerprint which is cleaner and clearer
and um lends to less error I guess and
so really the only concern is making
sure that we would train these folks um
I'll say a core cluster of these folks
at each agency that would be authorized
by by way of these statutes to take
those fingerprints and you know we do
that now with several different agencies
anyway to make sure they're taking
quality um um prints and understand what
they're doing and why they're doing what
we know how how to do it the right way
and things and so really um the good
news there and the only other concern is
well what happens if these people aren't
as well trained as the law enforcement
agencies and entities and things and and
we we've got I guess scenarios now where
we're dealing with non- law enforcement
folks that are involved in the criminal
justice information gathering process
and it seems to be working well and the
better news is is that um they're
submitting that stuff to us and they're
also submitting the paperwork that goes
along with the background check to us
and so we have the opportunity at the
department of safety to make sure that
we are validating I guess the
information that we're seeing
electronically against the paper records
that we would be getting from them to
process the entirety of the check and so
there's a couple of
um checks and balances in the process to
make sure that again non-law enforcement
folks that would be involved in this
process um not that they would
intentionally do anything wrong but you
know errors and mistakes aren't
happening because it's it's all coming
to us and we can verify and validate
before we would submit anything to the
FBI I see no further questions thank you
thank
you the chair calls um Attorney John
Williams from
DHHS
chairman Roy and members of the criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee for
the record my name is John Williams I'm
the legislative director for the
Department of Health Human Services and
I'm here today to provide information to
this committee uh relative to HB 1197 uh
HB 1197 as you've already heard from the
bill sponsor uh certainly comes to you
with very important goals here which is
to allow for those who are employed uh
at least in the sections referencing the
department or volunteering in certain
areas to making sure that they're being
appropriately screened but given the
option to having uh those particular set
of fingerprints taken by those executive
branch agencies identified in the
legislation um it's already been
identified that um the bill does not
have a fiscal analysis from the
legislative budget Assistance office as
you know uh the attorneys who draft
legislation make it determination
working through the office of
legislative Services whether or not that
there is an impact greater than
$10,000 uh if you uh refer you to RSA
1444 that requires that all bills having
a fiscal impact greater than $10,000
shall shall uh have a fiscal note um on
it the good news is is that if it wasn't
identified for a robust fiscal analysis
so you could understand the um
appropriation issues and other resource
issues required uh under RSA
1446 uh Roman 5 again that's 1440 colon
46 Roman five uh uh which is under the
legislative budget Assistance Office
statutes that this committee is vested
like all other standing committees uh
both in the house and the Senate under
that RSA to uh upon a motion of a
Committee Member to having in in of
course with the majority of the
committee uh having a fiscal analysis
done in the bill um that would perhaps
be helpful to this committee in any
other committee where this bill May
travel so you get a better understanding
with some baseline information as to the
economics behind the bill um the
department is here specifically on two
specific sections of the bill I think
that section one of the bill that the uh
sponsor and working along with the
Department of Safety did a wonderful job
describing in section one of the bill
the current process and you'll see that
it's an incredibly detailed and
important process that's followed when
they're doing these particular criminal
background checks and as it relates to
agencies with this 24 plus section Bill
there are two sections that I'm here
today on not on the other section but
section 7 of the bill and section nine
so drawing your attention to page uh
page one um and I'm going to get my
glasses because I think it's probably a
different number it's page four um and
at the very bottom starting on line 36
it discusses in section 7 the use of
cannabis for therapeutic purposes and
the alternative treatment U requirements
and it Contin on the following page on
page uh five uh relative to the
requirement that uh individuals or are
agents under therapeutic cannabis
programs are required
to it's here yeah P page
four line 36 section section seven I
need to slow down is what I need to do
yeah and number
36 okay section go ahead chairman wor it
would not be the first time I'd be
testifying on the wrong Bill and
apologizing so here we go so as as you
see uh moving to the second page
starting from lines one through line 16
there is an amendment that would add the
the following to the sentence uh the
applicant meaning uh the alternative
treatment uh Center or their agents
shall shall submit with a release form a
complete set of electronic F
fingerprints taken by a qualified law
enforcement agency U which is your local
Municipal level law enforcement agencies
uh or uh in current law but struck here
an authorized employee of the Department
of Safety and now this is the additional
part or an authorized employee of the
Department of Health and services so our
read of this particular section as it
relates is a shall it's a mandatory and
the effective date of this legislation
which I certainly will get to uh as part
of uh my commentary uh is uh upon
passage at least for this section so the
representation I I would make to this
committee not knowing the exact answers
is certainly working with the Department
of Safety and and perhaps also other
agencies that currently are doing this
we can get a better handle on the
resources that are necessary to doing
this clearly there is likelihood of
greater than
$10,000 uh at least as it relates to our
section of the bill uh for getting these
very important machines uh we actually
did a pilot uh within the last decade
where we were starting to do very much
what this bill is suggesting uh to help
with the the backlog it was very good to
hear from the testimony from the
Department of Safety from Captain Muzzy
that they they are um and I don't want
to over quote because it's obviously
recorded but that they've caught up with
the um with the backlog which is great
news to hear so those individuals
particularly who are seeking employment
uh at uh various uh can certainly be
employed sooner sooner than later um I
now want to draw your attention on the
same page page five to line 27 page five
line 27 which is section n of the bill
dealing with residential care and child
placing agencies so as you'll see here
this also requires uh that a criminal
background check through the FBI is
required for individuals who are
employed by child care agencies giving
you the numbers there are thousands of
individuals who do this very important
work for the state of New Hampshire so
the um position that this could be
absorbed using um current resources I
think at least in this specific instance
and I think providing that information
to safety would be helpful to for them
to understand that our current staff are
already dedicated ated to reviewing
licensing and other issues in in this
particular area and that if we're
required now to take on the additional
responsibility as I mentioned we're
talking over thousands of individuals
that it would be contemplated that we'd
need an additional staff position or at
least a part-time staff position to be
able to accomplish what is required
under this legislation so with that said
I I just would respectfully request that
this committee consider the fiscal
implications as it relates to the
legislation and perhaps on motion of a
member of this committee have the LBA
directed to completing a financial
analysis so that you the bill sponsor
Department of Safety would have a better
understanding as to what it would take
in terms of the resources at the end of
the day we go to section 24 of the bill
and rounding the corner towards the end
of my commentary um is the Task Force
that's created just a couple quick items
for your consideration uh as a part of
that is you'll note that that the
reporting date for the initial report
was very thoughtfully put on November
1st of 2024 and my understanding in
speaking with the bill sponsor who's a
wonderful person I've worked with him
many times in the past he cares very
much about New Hampshire citizens that
uh the first report would be an
opportunity to provide the legislature
with feedback in terms of what these
costs were to be built into the 2627
budget um I would respectfully say
because the the uh effective date is
upon passage this would be in 202 5 we
do not have any Appropriations and I'm
sure the department of safety that
performs this uh uh current function now
already has within their budget at least
identified certain resources uh to
making their shop be able to do what
they do but we do not I represent uh to
this committee we do not have the
resources to be able to do what this
legislation contemplates so at a minimum
uh going to the last page on the
effective date for your consideration
you may want to consider pushing that
out to June 30th of 202 5 that's the end
of the B any of the current budget to
allow for a thoughtful response in the
task force report as to identifying
necessary resources and any language
changes because I do understand that the
goal here is to establish a policy in
this legislation it would have been uh
uh uh the Department's preference to uh
keep the task force portion of this bill
and have this further issue explored but
I do understand and appreciate after my
conversation with the bill sponsor that
there's a desire to set the policy now
not later it is an option and one that
we were certainly um going to suggest to
the committee to consider having that
language Shelf ready for hb2 as part of
the next banian budget rather than
mandating items without having an
appropriation associated with it even if
you do push out that particular
effective date so with that said the
only other drafting consideration uh
chairman Roy that I would suggest the
committee that on page 10 of the bill
you'll see under Roman D um three which
is the last series of the um duties of
the items that they're going to be
reviewing for this uh task force that
there be consideration to putting in
additional language that would say
something to the effect of identify
necessary funding and other resources
including Staffing and other IT issues
uh for the state executive branch
agencies and importantly political
subdivisions because you'll see that
Beyond just touching upon our agency and
other state agency it also touches upon
political subdivisions within the state
so they're would be particularly
important the other item for your
consideration because I know that the
legislature typically allows for late
filed legislation if recommendations are
coming from legislative um created
commission's task force in this occasion
we in the task force you have uh the
department of safety the commissioner
being the lead and then the state
agencies there's no reference to a
legislature and I apologize to Bill
sponsor it's just something I picked up
when I was reading through the language
again for the third time uh over the
last few weeks that there may be some
consideration to having a legislator
because that would carry greater weight
than to getting it into uh either the
budget or some type of remedial
legislation if you determine that what
is in the four corners of this very
important bill uh that need to be
changed or tweaked based upon the
information so it's the cart and horse
uh analysis essentially that we would
propose with that and leaving some
oxygen in the room that concludes my
commentary before the committee and I am
available to take
questions thank you um with regard to
the two sections you pointed out that
you said um would incur an immediate
cost I I'm the way I'm reading it I may
be wrong it says or it doesn't say it
says shall be completed by a qualified
law enforcement
agency or an authorized employee so how
do you read that to me that you have to
do that right away and represent Roy
that is a great question and I am an
active member of New Hampshire bar my
current role is legislative so I'm here
in my legislative capacity and I'm sure
you can ask the question of others uh
who will be coming to testify
that I think there's enough ambiguity
there because if the public sees this
there's going to be an expectation that
they're going to be able to come to the
Department of Health and Human Services
if they're seeking a job uh in the child
care um um with a Child Care Agency as a
worker that we're going to be up and
running on the effective date of this
bill and I think that that's not a fair
representation of that and it's possible
that um that um your thoughts that this
is discretionary um would be one re View
and one um a certain um position on the
language but the regular public is just
going to read this and saying why aren't
they opening up shop here and our
responses because we don't have the
resources nor do we have a memorandum of
understanding which does not require
legislation we can work those out with
the um Department of Safety also we're
talking about certification and training
for the staff it's not just a matter of
using existing staff it's staff that are
trained and certified in this very
important area around confidentiality
issues and and how to to run it so I
know it's a little bit longer winded but
I think the answer to your question is I
think you rais a good point that it
could be viewed as discretionary uh
we're taking a more cautious approach
that one could make the uh similar
argument because of the word shall and
right now if particularly in the um area
of uh the first one I identified with
the shell if they could go to a local
law enforcement person walks up there
they're going to take their fingerprints
or the department of safety so it's not
like safety can say oh did you try your
local law enforcement agency uh it's in
statute you you could go there it's an
or
and I would imagine the public would say
nope you're responsible for for doing
this because it's in law but I do agree
with you that your your your take on
that is a re re um a
reasonable that is
discretionary he gther thank you for
taking my question um what was the date
that you wanted to push out yes so if we
go to the final page of the bill on page
11 on line S it currently reads reads
the remainder of the ACT shall take
effect upon its passage and it's just
it's just a suggestion to this committee
that if the goal here is to align this
as the bill sponsor uh very thoughtfully
said to be built into the budget you
really have to have the other language
aligned with that to allow that
opportunity to take place and if you
want to establish policy now that
effective date should be June 30 June
30th of 2025 which ends the Binum for
the current budget June 30th 2025 thank
you
thank you for your testimony and thank
you anyone else wishing to testify in
this bill wasn't
testified seeing none I'm going to
appoint a subcommittee on this um
representative rhs representative Muse
representative Manion representative
Newman um I'd like a two-e turnaround
please address the concerns raised by
DHHS and work with the sponsor and the
um Captain Muzzy please and that I close
the public hearing thank
Monday um I hereby open a public hearing
on House Bill 1295 and invite sponsor to
assist the
bill good morning uh I am actually going
to be introducing this bill on behalf of
representative Bale the prime sponsor
I'm also a co-sponsor on the
bill as it currently stands therapeutic
cannabis patients are held to a higher
legal standard simply by virtue of their
status as a particular uh uh as needing
a particular form of relief um in the
event that they commit the same exact
crime as anyone else in this in the
state they face a higher
charge now personally I think this is
interesting because the defining Factor
as to whether uh whether or not someone
is certified as a qualifying therapeutic
cannabis patient is a health matter it's
not a moral
matter if in fact they do transgress in
that way they already and still will if
this bill is passed um will have their
certification revoked and they will be
subject to the existing charges for this
crime which is sale of
cannabis what this bill does is simply
remove the legal in inequity while
leaving the consequences of revoking
one's certification it is a
straightforward measure and I believe it
deserves a straightforward
recommendation from this Committee of
OTP uh thank you for your time and
consideration I have passed around the
prime sponsors uh letter to the
committee and I'm happy to take
questions but I also see that uh
representative Wendy Thomas is here and
she probably get uh can probably answer
them better than I
can thank
you anyone
else represent Thomas
no questions un see
any that's Thomas thanks
she good morning honorable members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Wendy Thomas I represent the town of
marac Hillsboro
12 and um I support this
bill okay so uh the therapeutic cannabis
program progr in New Hampshire was
established in
2013 that's 11 years ago um and it was
passed by an admittedly older
legislation New Hampshire is known for
uh having members that that are that
tend to be a little older the
significance of this is that our
generation the older generation was
taught that cannabis is a horrible drug
it's used by black people it's used by
brown people it's used by criminals
uh when we established this program
people saw the need for a therapeutic
cannabis program to be established in
New Hampshire however they couldn't
really disengage from the Cannabis
equals criminal activity and so we we
allowed the program to go forward but we
put in very significant guard rails
because some people believed that this
was going to initiate criminal activity
in New
Hampshire guess what 11 years later it
has not um for the record also I am a a
patient in the therapeutic cannabis
program I have been since
2017 and since 2017 there has not been
one day that I have not used therapeutic
cannabis I use it for chronic
pain and in the last two years I use it
uh for
cancer uh
so in addition to this recently the US
government has uh released a report find
uh with the findings that cannabis is
not addictive cannabis is not a gateway
drug and cannabis is effective as
medication this is really good news for
th those of us in the
program
so I understand when the program was
established that we wanted guardrails in
there we thought there was going to be
all of these bad people remember the the
hoopla when we um established uh
dispensaries around New Hampshire and
everybody was like not in my
neighborhood not in my neighborhood we
have a dispensary in marac and nobody
even knows it's there it's very discreet
it's very quiet um this is a self-
policing
program if you get into trouble we
expect to be punished I mean we're not
above the law but if we get into trouble
because of the program our card our
access to the program is also revoked no
one wants to take that chance certainly
not someone who's sick uh so I'm just
here to remind you that just because we
are sick just because we need effective
medication that does not make us
criminals and so hold us accountable
just as you would everybody else but
just because we use cannabis don't give
us extra
penalties I'll take any questions if
anybody has any thank you um
so the current state of the law is if
you are a um member of the Cannabis
program and you purchase your your your
cannabis from a a dispensary and you
sell it to someone you would be subject
to the penalties of 318 b26 correct and
if someone else gets arrested for
selling marijuana they too would be
subject to 31826 correct there are um
and I know that Michael HT is is in the
audience too there are added penalties
just for being in the Cannabis program
okay that's what I'm trying to get at
what are the added penalties do you want
me to just defer to yes if you could
sure that's he would answer it better
than than I could okay um representative
sik thank you very much and thank you
for taking my question and I apologize
when I bolt out in a moment I'm going to
go meet my elementary schoolers but um
could you explain a little bit about um
what are the uh currently legal in New
Hampshire reasons why people would be
able to get therapeutic
cannabis so to get in the program there
is an application and on the application
right now we have listed criteria so you
have to have a significant chronic
illness a terminal illness um PTSD um is
included so there's a list of criteria
the problem with that is that the the
Physicians have to use that list and
there are other things that that could
apply for example menstrual cramps um
cannabis is very very helpful for
menstrual cramps um long covid um we're
finding that people are getting um IBS
irritable bowel syndrome not Crohn's
disease so technically that would not
fit into the program however cannabis
greatly helps um digestive
issues um so so we're trying to change
that I've got a bill right now in that
would let any physician who is
knowledgeable of cannabis recom the
program they can't prescribe the program
they can recommend the program to any
patient whom they think it would benefit
so it would it would keep us from
practicing medicine and coming back
every year putting in new criteria but
we do have established
criteria reprentative rhods thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question yes it so the the Cannabis that
you're speaking of is a prescription
correct no medical medical cannabis is
not a
prescription medical Physicians so MDS
and and people who are qualified and I
think we had um nurse practitioners um
they can recommend the program they
cannot prescribe the program because of
how it is scheduled and it's an illegal
substance according to a federal um but
they're they're changing that they're in
the process of changing it so it is not
a prescription it is a
recommendation
however then you work with people in the
in the dispensary who have knowledge and
and I used to work in a dispensary so
the first thing we would do is sit down
with a patient go over their medical
history um match up their their symptoms
and and get them onto a a therapeutic
cannabis program low and
slow which means that you have a tiny
you start off with a tiny
amount thank you for your testimony oh
excuse me represent m
so I'm I'm a little confused so um
because of the way we Define a
prescription there isn't you're saying
that there isn't another provision in
New Hampshire law that would actually
make it illegal for somebody to give
their therapeutic cannabis away to
somebody else or to sell it to them is
that no okay no I'm not that I don't
Maybe This Is Lost in Translation no if
if I purchase cannabis through the
program and then I wanted to sell it to
somebody that's illegal whether I'm in
the program or
not um you're you're still you look like
you're a little confused followup so the
the thing that makes it illegal is this
specific statute or is there another
statute where that conduct would be
prohibited under New Hampshire
law oh I see what you're saying
um I believe that it's this statute um
however so so this addresses therapeutic
cannabis specifically however if
somebody sells cannabis on the street um
you're saying that you're I'm not I'm
not sure I think um director halt would
be the one to answer that go
ahead I I think the I think the root of
it is just um my confusion over whether
or not there may be a redundancy in our
law so for example do we have two laws
in New Hampshire that cover this conduct
one is in this statute and one is maybe
somewhere else I believe that that's
what's happening yes so so there is
there is a penalty for selling cannabis
um if you're not in the program if you
are in the program you have that same
penalty with an added penalty be just
because you're in the program thank
you thank you my pleasure thank
you U the chair recognizes Michael
Hol good morning Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program with
the Department of Health and Human
Services um I'm happy to answer
questions um I didn't plan to testify
but um I'm I'm sure I can help a little
uh here and eliminate the um
technicalities of the bill um the
department doesn't take a position on
this bill um as the uh the sponsor and
representative Thomas indicated there
are there is an extra penalty for
therapeutic cannabis patients um in New
Hampshire state law if they sell
cannabis to somebody else RSA
318b as
referenced in the bill creates penalties
for anyone who sells cannabis
uh it's 318 b26 a whole section on
penalties that includes um the sale of
uh of
cannabis when the therapeutic cannabis
law was passed in
2013 an additional provision was added
to 318 b26 and that's referenced in line
seven and8 of the bill the
repeal so 318
b26 Roman
9A establishes an additional penalty
that additional penalty in again in
addition to the penalties that already
exist for SE for selling cannabis for
anyone the additional penalty
establishes for any amount a class B
felony a maximum term of imprisonment of
more not more than seven years and a
fine not more than
$300,000 in addition to the 200,000 or
500,000 or the other felonies involved
with selling cannabis so what the intent
of this bill as I believe it is to
eliminate the extra penalty for
therapeutic cannabis
patients if they are convicted of
selling any cannabis to an unauthorized
person to the best of your knowledge is
there a similar law that affects people
that sell their prescription drugs like
if I have a prescription for oxycodone
and I sell it is there a double penalty
for those for that or just I'm not aware
of any extra penalty for the sale of a
prescription medication except for for
cannabis correct thank you represent
M and I know your knowledge is primarily
of New Hampshire but I wonder are there
uh are there other states that sort of
have this two-tiered penalty uh for
people who sell therapeutic cannabis I
not aware of any state that does but I'm
not aware of any state that doesn't
thank you I'm
sorry thank you for your testimony this
morning
you're
welcome chair calls uh The Honorable
Maria
Perez can you check and see if she
walked on to the
hall good morning uh thank you for
allowing me to speak this my name is
Maria Perez I'm a St representative from
District 43 in Milford I'm here in um
speaking on support at
1295 um as someone who suffered from uh
chronic illness um I have chronic lme
disease and um right now I'm dealing
with uh illness on my kidneys uh that's
one of the reason that I'm supporting
this bill because there's many people
like myself uh they suffer with chronic
illness they
um we wish to to be able to
use Canabis without being penalized and
that's one of the reason that I'm asking
uh the committee to support this
Bill thank you any questions for
representative
pz seeing none thank you for sharing
this
morning is there anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill or was not
testified in this bill excuse me
representative sitech you have a
question uh Mr actually uh if I'm
wondering what are typical dose at large
what are typical doses of therapeutic
cannabis thank you for the question um
Everybody metabolizes cannabis a little
differently um and so I have um worked
and I have met some people that use 100
migrs as a dose now if I had 100
milligrams I would be asleep that you
you can't overdose I mean you'll you'll
just it's not like alcohol you're not
going to end up in the ER you're just
going to go to sleep when I take a dose
I average between 2.5 and 10 milligrams
10 is a bit high so I take 2.5 to 5
during the day I usually take it twice
during the day and you're never going to
see me inebriated because that's if
you're using the therapeutic program to
get high you're using it incorrectly
it's to manage our symptoms so I take
the lowest dose that I need to manage my
pain and then I take 10 milligrams in
the evening and that helps me sleep
through the
night so I I take what are called micro
does so that's why it's very difficult
to to prescribe it you need somebody who
understands the how it works with the
human body and typically even with with
patients that have experienced
experienced with cannabis we start them
at 2.5 to 5
milligram thank you I think it's got a
follow
up it's just amazing because 27 grams
make an ounce so this these are very
tiny amounts yes that's the whole the
again the therapeutic cannabis program
is not to get
inebriated thank you represent
Muse just one more question um how when
this is actually dispensed when when
therapeutic cannabis is is it's
dispensed are we talking about something
that size of a coffee can something the
size of prescription bottle drug bottle
I mean how much of it actually commonly
gets dispensed so first of all it
depends how you you take it so so I very
rarely smoke cannabis I don't I cough
you know I'm not I'm not good at that
the only time that I smoke cannabis is
when um I'm in very severe pain because
it hits the pain like that you know but
then I can't drive I can't read I can't
do anything except watch TV and eat
Doritos um but uh you know some people
take
capsules um and the the capsules could
be 2.5 or 5 milligrams or you know even
higher um I have cream that's infused
with with cannabis and so um I use that
on my joints because I have arthritis
from Lyme disease um I use Edibles I use
gummies most of the time that's that's
probably the biggest thing so it's and
it's usually sold in in up two ounces so
you're looking at if you've seen the
pictures of cannabis you know the flower
the bud like one to two buds would
be you know how much it's dispensed as
in New Hampshire we're only allowed to
buy 2 ounces of cannabis at a time
there's a bill going forward that would
allow 4 ounces which would bring it into
line with what's being proposed for the
legal legalization of cannabis program
thank you if I'm not mistaken the the
amount allowed monthly is based on
the the grams of THC not necessarily in
other words you could buy a batch of
brownies that doesn't count the weight
of the brownies isn't it's correct it's
the am it's the product and and um I
just want to correct you said monthly
and it's not monthly we can we can buy
every 10 days okay yeah okay but my
point was is it's not calculated based
on the weight of the product you're
buying it's the amount of the pro THC or
marijuana correct correct correct thank
all
right representative
Newman I just want to clear up the
difference between CBD and THC it's the
it's the amount of not CHC medical
medical cannabis it's just it's the
amount of THC that is in that's allowed
I think CBD is like CBD um is simply
another cannabinoid um so you have THC
and you have you know the the plant
contains all kinds they're called
cannabinoids but THC is the one that
gets you inebriated so that's the one
that you you kind of have to be careful
but in the therapeutic program there are
some products that have high high high
THC um if you if you you know if you
take that you're going to be inebriated
now for my cancer I take a product
that's 50% THC but I take a little tiny
tiny amount and and I take it at night
so I can I can sleep it off um and the
other thing with a product being high in
THC is the first time you use it you're
going to be knocked off your block you
know you're going to be knocked you're
going to be very drowsy and everything
and then you're going to learn just like
we learned when we when we started with
whiskey or scotch or anything like that
you don't take as much the next time
because you don't like that feeling you
know so CBD is a non euphoric canono
that's used um it's used to relax the
body it's used um a lot for muscle
relaxation but if you have pain you have
to have some THC not much but
some okay thank you that's all the pot
questions for today do you is it
relative to the bill or about okay wait
one more go ahead go
ahead so is this essentially
housekeeping legislation it seems like
we're just trying to clean up
oversight it is housekeeping um I
wouldn't I wouldn't classify it as an
oversight as as more as it was it was an
unnecessary protection that people
believed were needed for the program
when the program was initiated program's
been running fine for 11 years we don't
have the criminals and the monsters that
that were anticipated so this is
just making it more more just it's just
making it more just that was not that
wasn't good but it's making it more more
socially accept not that's wrong too
it's making it more fair there we go
taking away the double penalty there you
go but that I close public
hearing sorry take a um 15minute recess
and we'll be right
back
they're not here today Jen's not here
Bradley's notle not
here
yeah okay I'm opening an executive
session on House Bill 1295 five and I
move
OTP seconded by representative here at
gaite I'll speak to the motion um after
hearing the testimony on the bill it
does not make any sense to have an extra
or an additional penalty or more
enhanced penalty for someone who sells
their their cannabis versus someone who
sells their their other prescription
drugs this seems to have been targeted
just at cannabis patients it's already
illegal to sell your to sell marijuana
so the having an enhanced penalty for
that versus someone who for example um
sells their oxycodone um doesn't make
any sense at all so that's why I would
support passing the bill and encourage
others to do so as well would you like
to speak to your second representative
Harry gather I agree with you 100% thank
you
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role motion on the
floor is out to pass yes Vice chair
roads yes representative Pratt not room
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tzar yes
representative Harriet Gite
representative Muse yes representative
Balden representative Murphy oh also no
here representative Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative silik yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chals yes motion is unanimous what does
it
count 16 to zero motion passes 16 to Zer
unanimous um any objection to consent
see seeing none it will go on consent I
hereby close the executive session House
Bill 1295
and open the public he on on House Bill
1339 and invite the sponsor to nce the
bill good morning members of the
criminal justice
committee I'm introducing uh HB 1339
FN I'm representative John Stone
representing Sullivan 8
and basically this bill as filed would
involve a change in the background
checks done by the state and by uh
utilizing Nicks I have uh two amendments
to this bill based on some conversations
I had with constituents uh some gun
dealers and some other individuals who
had concerns over the amended
language so one of the bills I have uh
going to be submitting for the amendment
is that we had some issues that arose
last week during testimony on returning
firearms and the amendment that I have
outlined which is uh
531 basically I passed out to everybody
this morning would uh put some
guardrails up for the returning of
firearms if anyone has any questions I
would most likely entertain them um so
we have two amendments it your proposed
the to
ignore 520 in favor of 531 is that
correct yes after a discussion this
morning with the Dual amendments it
looks like I would like to request a
subcommittee to further review uh
0531 okay um can you just briefly tell
us what the bill does um as far as NX
goes uh the new Amendment would it end
up uh utilizing Nicks for the return of
firearms and set parameters with a
requirement of court dates business days
to facilitate that uh during some of the
testimony we heard last week which
caused this amendment to be drafted
there was definitely uh some issues when
it comes to the returning of firearms
after someone is no longer considered to
be
prohibited is this related to um
protective orders or what is this
related to initially it was uh under
protective orders at
173b and also under 633
3A which is also criminal proceeding
such as bail orders and other uh issued
statutory Authority by the court so it
doesn't specifically apply only to One
c3b issues it would refer to someone who
perhaps is out on bail they're uh they
have gone to court their court has
charges have been dismissed to
facilitate their guns being
returned okay did you find out if this
is an early bill or not this is not an
early Bill therefore uh okay we're not
restricted on the time frames to get it
done okay um unless anyone has question
questions I'll assign a subcommittee and
we can dig into it
further go ahead representative
site it's this um is the I don't see the
issue the connection between a
background check and return of weapons
is the is the nub of this that you need
a background check if your weapons are
being restored what what's the Nexus
here representative what happens
currently in the cases of a 173b if
you're under a protective order that
protective order
expires once that order expires as you
heard testimony last week or you may
have not if I can't recall if you were
here or not but an individual can go to
a Firearms dealer purchase a brand new
firearm that same day however the
firearms that are being held by the
police or by an FFL would actually be
required to have a court order to
release those Firearms which means a
separate appearance before a court of
jurisdiction to grant
that AB
zuse I I do have a a question because
one of your amendments seems to be
almost like a completely different bill
from the one you originally proposed um
Amendment uh
2024 uh
0531 um on line one States amend the
title of the bill by replacing it uh
with with the following and then on line
five it says amend the bill by replacing
all after the enacting Clause I don't
actually see anything in the amendment
um that contains anything from the
original Bill unless I'm missing
something uh no the new Amendment which
is the
531h is that the one you're referring
to that one would be replacing the
language itself this is kind of a
background issue which should be
Germaine to the original
Bill your Amendment actually replaces
your bill correct
okay it depends whether or not it's
germine whether or not it can be
replaced the whole bill as long as it's
Germain to the topic of the original
bill um which is using using the state
as well as Nicks to restore fire so
that's pretty much the same subject um
okay further
questions okay seeing none I will Appo a
subcommittee on this and I'll announce
the names before we leave today thank
you thank you is there anyone else
wishing to testify in this bill who has
not testified seeing none I hereby close
the public hearing on House Bill
1339 and I will open the public
hearing on House Bill
1462 and invite one of the sponsors to
introduce the
bill
good morning Mr chair and criminal
justice committee I am representa of
Linda Harriet Gite out of NASA and I
will be
um providing the information for this
bill
um the bill would mandate state that law
enforcement reports all suspected hate
crimes to the Civil Rights unit of the
Attorney General's office within 72
hours it would also mandate that the
Attorney General's office create and
maintain a public database of these hate
crimes and submit an analysis of the
data to the governor Senate President
and Speaker of the House on an annual
basis this database would not include
any identifying information for either
the victims or suspects in these
cases this legislation is necessary
because currently there is no mandate
for this information to be gathered or
maintained by any law enforcement agency
upon reaching out to various Municipal
police departments none were able to
detail a process they have for reporting
these types of
crimes we worked with the Attorney
General's office in drafting this
language and they have said they will be
sending written testimony to the
committee and I thank you for listening
to
me thank you uh representative are you
in a position to answer questions on
this no I think that they're going to be
be folks after me that probably would
answer them best the only one we have so
far is
uh who they're coming she just okay okay
all right thank you thank you oh him for
last cool
sag question for L one question oh go
ahead thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to take a question thank you for
taking a question Linda representative
goth right I apologize um I just wanted
to ask knowing what you have gone
through in Nashville I wonder if you
could illustrate for the committee what
members of the city board and Nash have
gone through and some of the things that
have happened that uh cause you to bring
this bill forward
oh well I can probably give I've been
here since 79 and I probably give tons
of examples of things that have happened
that have not gone into this category
that should have gone into this category
and and we should have records of it and
um around hate crimes and I think even
last year I think when we had a
representative that um there was
graffiti um um put on a um the side of a
building downtown in Nashua you know um
speaking of him and he was um Latino
so we've looked at we have we have
currently today there's a black
restaurant in one of um downtown in NASA
and they actually plased the nword all
over his property and his business so
for us we feel that we're not not
getting the the data captured where it
needs to be captured and that should be
State data that's captured for um hate
crimes thank you you're
welcome represent
s thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record I am laurren
selig I represent Durham which is
straford County District 10 and I um am
fully in support of this bill I um have
personally been the victim of um hate
crime activity uh at various points over
the course of My Life um including when
I was 8 years old and had someone spray
paint our driveway with a 20ft swastika
and juw go home um and um I did not live
in New Hampshire at that time but it was
was handled by the uh local police
department being saying basically oh
that's too bad and there was no further
action taken um wasn't reported anywhere
recorded anywhere um we know from
organizations outside of New Hampshire
that for example uh crimes of
anti-Semitism have increased
tremendously in the past several years
um but it's not tracked in New Hampshire
as a New Hampshire specific resource we
know that hate crimes against people of
color have increased across the state
but again there's no specific data and
without data we don't have a way to
address it right um I I had been hoping
to add to this bill something requiring
school districts to report incidents at
their schools and discovered some
technicalities that we have to work
through before we can do that but um the
the reality is that these incidences are
continuing to happen the um they're
isn't great recordkeeping there's not a
great way to see what the trends are so
that we can work on ways to address it
hopefully stop the cycle of hate crimes
and look for ways to remedy the issue
and so I think it's really important
that we create a better and stronger
database by having this go to the the
AG's office thank
you thank
you representative
an thank you Mr chair and and thank you
representative zelik um I'm wondering I
know you know we had spoken about um the
process of restorative justice um what
we call it in our school district is
restorative community and I think a lot
of times when we're talking about
compiling the data uh what we're
thinking about we need to do with that
is Target law enforcement but I think
there are other Alternatives and i' I'd
love for you to speak to that because
this kind of um notion of restorative
justice is just that especially for
youth who may um be doing for a lack of
a better way dumb kid stuff um that ends
up uh you know that is considered a hate
crime and in other ways that we can
address that and help to remedy the
problem absolutely I mean I'm I'm not an
expert in the law I'm not a lawyer um
you know I I don't want to pretend to be
but we know that uh juveniles at a
certain age are are sometimes charged as
adults and including hate crimes which
also have Federal implications but
beyond just New Hampshire
implications um restorative justice
models look at fin ways of having people
identify why they created a problem or
why they took an action that they did
and then making whole the person that
they damaged so for example if um
someone hung a noose in front of
someone's home and caused them trauma
and fear as a result of the Noose and
and words that might be affiliated with
it um we might you know we could punish
them by giving them a fine assessing
them a fine or giving them jail time
which may or may not depending on the
levels of it of it um may or may not
accomplish a goal of having them no
longer create uh commit those kinds of
hate crimes whereas a restorative model
would allow us to help them to identify
the cause of it I don't know that that
goes directly to this bill no um but I
think that by tracking like if there are
pockets of crime like if we know for
example that in one Community it's
happening a lot then maybe we look at
what are the Dynamics in that community
that can be repaired thank you I just
wanted to speak to what this St is
useful for yeah thank
you that oh representative Newman I just
wanted to verify that there's no
identifying data in this that it's a
random number that would just describe
what what happened right it's a random
number but perhaps you know like if
we're seeing for example that in one
town or Community there's a huge number
and in other towns there aren't then we
have a better idea of how to address and
and look at
resources thank you chair calls uh
representative
Perez thank you again for allowing me to
speak uh my name is Maria Perez I'm a
state representative from District 43 in
Milford I'm here to uh speak in support
of
1462 one of the reason that I'm
supporting this bill because
probably many of you know I was a victim
of couple times
already um harassing uh because of my
background and many people in my my
culture they they've been getting emails
hateful emails telling them that they
need to go back where they came from or
they don't have the right to to be
alive couple months ago I received a
email from a why nationalist group here
in uhans telling me
then my family needs to go back to
Cuba and then I'm I'm a myo just because
my mom is an indigenous person and my
dad is a a white
person and then my f my family is not
welcome here and then he put my personal
information in the website which is very
danger that puts my family in danger and
this is not the first time that this
person is doing it it's been happening a
couple times and every time that I go to
the police department I mean what I've
been told is like please come back and
tell us when something real happened so
that mean I have to wait till I get hurt
or one one of my reals get hurt for
someone to do something about hateful
and hate crimes here in new hire that's
one of the reason I'm doing this because
I'm not the only one many families going
through this and people not paying
enough attention people think that new
hire is safe for people who look like me
but it's not we have a lot of hate and
it's happening more and more and people
now feel like more they can be more
vocal about
it please pay attention we need to keep
people safe we're not here to erase
anyone in anyone we're not here to say
I'm better than you or you're better
than me I just want to have it
equal equal R like everyone
else I don't feel safe anymore to be
honest every time that I come in and
testify or every time that I vought in a
bill my name gets put in public and
sometime not on the right way I don't
feel safe hate crimes are happening and
it happen more because people feel they
have the right to do it thank you thank
you for your
testimony the chair recognizes Lind Jak
house
hello members of the committee my name
is Lind Jak house and I live in Dover
and I am a queer non-binary transperson
who is a co-founder of 603 equality a
Statewide advocacy Organization for
lgbtq granite Staters I want to thank
all of the Reps for introducing this
bill um after I approached
representative Murray wanting to make
hate crime information more transparent
I've been involved with lgbtq Community
organizing in New Hampshire since
2017 and have called been called upon
many times to Rally train de escalators
and community members to respond to hate
activity I was somewhat surprised to
find out that local law enforcement in
New Hampshire are not even required to
report hate crimes to the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office it's clear
that we need to take some steps toward
better data collection and transparent
parency I feel generally safe in my
community of do as a white queer person
who isn't often seen as transgender or
non-binary but that is not true for many
others no matter who we are whether
we're black indigenous Latina Asian or
white lgbtq cisgender or heterosexual we
all want to live in safe communities
where we don't have to fear violence
where our voices are heard and our
rights are respected no one wants to
live in a community where crimes based
on hate and bigotry happen but
unfortunately hate crimes have happened
in many corners of our state some of
these make the news but not all do
instead of turning away from these
problems everyone living in the granite
state no matter their race gender sexual
orientation should have transparent
information about the hate crimes that
are happening near them those targeted
by hate crimes should also have their
safety and privacy respected without
being forced into News Headlines by
creating a database that includes
pertinent Anonymous information about
types of hate crimes committ committed
in towns and cities across New Hampshire
and by requiring the Attorney General to
summarize and analyze hate crimes and
report to the governor Senate President
and Speaker of the House of
Representatives we can begin to better
assess and analyze the problem and help
Granite Staters make informed decisions
that may help them avoid violence thank
you see no questions thank you for your
testimony chair calls captain
muzy
good morning again Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh again my
name is Victor Muzzy I'm here to
represent uh the New Hampshire
Department of Safety uh on this topic
and would simply say that we we have a
neutral position I guess uh relative to
um this bill what I can offer is
currently under RSA 106 b14 C which is
the Uniform Crime reporting system
statute and I guess I'll read that in
part to uh which says law enforcement
agencies operating within the state of
New Hampshire shall submit crime reports
to the Department of Safety Division of
State Police based on the specifications
prescribed by the Federal Bureau of
Investigations criminal justice
Information Services Uniform Crime
reporting
program uh full sentence there um
basically the report it then the RSA
then goes on to talk about number of
offenses and arrests and crimes
occurring Within jurisdictions um
reporting requirements um relative to
when those will be compiled and it says
July 1st of the following year and we
basically have to make those reports
available to to several entities and
members of the public if you know upon
their inquiry uh section two talks about
um if a law enforcement agency has no
records management system with niers u
relative to ners capabilities that the
department of safety would be um provide
them a means by which to report and
that's important because currently uh as
part of that process and part of the
ners or UCR requirements we and all all
agencies that operate in the state are
currently collecting um bias motivation
as it relates to the following
categories race ethnicity and ancestry
religious bias sexual orientation bias
disability bias gender bias and gender
identity bias so we're already capturing
that anyhow um I suppose
um with respect to the bill I think
maybe that should be shared on a more
intimate basis with the Attorney
General's office for the purpose that
out is outlined in the bill but I
thought it was important to at least
articulate that we are capturing that
now um and and collecting that now and
obviously have have to make it available
to those that don't have a records
management system in order to do that so
I offer that to the committee for for
their consideration relative to uh what
you've heard already today and I would
be happy to take any questions thank you
is that information that you collect or
any of it even the the the redacted
versions of it available to the
public the tally I guess is available to
the public by way of our ners uh
reporting website um and we have two
areas now that we we manage and maintain
one of those is more geared towards data
analysts I guess it's a little bit
harder to kind of sift through it's it's
um not as pretty to look at I guess but
it's there we are currently working on
um what we call um with our vendor it's
uh a TOS website and that's theme
oriented um I forget what the acronym
stands for But ultimately it's it's a
more userfriendly
um website that presents information in
a little bit more of a um I don't want
to say generic but easily more easy to
digest um
presentation and um we have three themes
on there right now with the intent to
expand that to six um and that will
include some domestic violence and I I
forget what the two the categories are
and so we we do have that I'll say
publicly available um it's not in
a desirable format I suppose but it it
is there and so um but again I think as
I as I understand and read this bill
it's it sort of sounds like the intent
would be to present that information to
the AG's office and then for them to
draft or create a report that's a little
bit more consumable I guess to those
interested in so
um
currently this information um is
available is it not from the FBI from
their website doesn't it track for
example you can sort how many crimes
against who who was theant who what was
the weapon used that type of thing yes
is that would that information that's
currently available from the FBI be any
different than
this well and I I what I can say is we
have a repository um that can be
searched specific to New Hampshire you
know and which is separate really from
the FBI's database the FBI's numbers I
guess should include New Hampshire's um
and so we have a third party vendor that
we work with that also works with the
FBI where we report um and make those
things available to our public I guess
sort of separate from the FBI but I'm
just asking is is it is the information
currently available or would this be
redundant or not would this be something
new that we could I see this as sort of
an add-on to what we're currently doing
to maybe make it a bit more consumable
and make it a bit more user friendly or
usable okay I guess what we provide is
um basically a tally you know you had
this number of crimes that were reported
as having this type of bias and so it it
doesn't offer I guess the total picture
that maybe the intent of this bill would
meaning it doesn't necessarily relate
the victims and the suspects and the
circumstances um at the moment so that's
I guess an add-on to what we're
currently doing this is to maybe make
that a little more
robust my my last question would be how
do in other words I want to be I want to
be confident in the data that I get so
if if how does the um State Police or
any Department submit data with regards
to a hate
crime is it after its investigated and
it's actually been determined to be a
hate crime or just that there was an
allegation that it was a hate crime
because what we don't want is to get
numbers from somewhere that just have
allegations that it could inflate the
numbers artificially correct and that
was a thought that I I had and we had
discussed and so at the moment I'm not
exactly sure if it's simply the fact
that there was an allegation there or
whether it was determined I'll say
through a conviction that it was in fact
a hate crime so I think we have to
probably get a little bit more clarity
around where that determination is made
and how if a victim is certainly
reporting that is that really what we
intend to capture and Report out on or
is the intent to capture and Report out
on proven cases I guess that were found
to be you know hate crime motivated um I
think a conviction will be too high of a
bar because plea Bargains happen and
then it goes away but I think there
should be some type of bar perhaps that
that the public can have confidence in
the numbers right and I don't you know
it's I guess it would be C or case
dependent or circumstance dependent to
say okay just because it was reported
this way through the investigation they
met this threshold and therefore we can
categorize it as a you know I don't know
what that threshold would be in the
investigation but certainly I mean a lot
of this is is would be up to the
victim's determination it's how the
victim feels given the circumstances and
it through the investigation I would
assume it's not something just made up
it would have to be quantifiable
certainly an image painted on someone's
driveway I would think is pretty clear
and convincing to the law enforcement
agency that okay yep
um I guess it would be case specific but
MH okay probably you're right conviction
level's too high I think it needs to be
through somewhere in the middle the
investigation representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm hoping you
can help me clarify something so under
RSA
651 and it's
651 B6 and a whole bunch of numbers um
it says when substantially motivated to
commit the crime because of hostility
towards the victim's religion race Creed
sexual orientation is defined in RSA uh
2149 so this is under the extended term
of imprisonment is what I'm looking at
so how would If This Were to be enacted
how would it be reported differently
because I'm I'm reading that it already
is reported differently if there's an
extended term of imprisonment for it
I don't think this bill would cause it
to be recorded any differently but
maybe summarized differently or again
what we're currently reporting is just a
tally to say this crime that was
reported was had a biased motivation
what I think the bill does is extend
extend that to gather and track the
surrounding circumstances information
about the victim information about the
suspect and so certainly the and I did
this morning at the enhanced penalty
statute that you're reading
um I think the intent there is if at the
conclusion of the trial the finding is
guilty and there is some provable
element suggestive of a bias motivation
or a hate crime then I think that's what
that statute is speaking
to so I don't know if that really
answers the question
but I'm not sure either okay
sorry representative
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm really
concerned about especially when we're
talking about hate crimes um the
prevention right we saw in our school
district uh kind of an explosion for a
while there of um of a variety of um
things that happened within the school
system but did not rise to the level of
a police investigation and so uh you've
said you know that this information is
gathered we've talked about kind of what
the threshold is I also think that that
would be very important uh information
to anonymously uh because you know uh
underage children things like that um
but that would also be useful
information for us targeting um
prevention and so I'm wondering is is
that information or to your knowledge is
uh would information that is happening
within the school district that doesn't
necessarily rise to the level of an
investigation is that also Quantified in
a way that can be useful for targeting
getting um prevention not that I'm aware
of I what I would Envision is if the the
district or the the school thought it
Rose to the level to call the police
certainly if the police came and took a
report and and took that information
that would be the only way that we the
state would end up to my knowledge that
W with that at all so if if the school
is privy to information that they don't
believe Rises to the level of calling
the police then I would say we would
through this means would not have that
that information which which is
important um if that's the overall goal
thank you representative Stone thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so just to clarify if it's a
juvenile offense would that necessarily
be tracked or not currently
tracked if the suspect were a juvenile
it would be tracked the difficulty would
be is um certainly for this purpose it
would be anonymized anyways relative to
so I I think
tracking it whether the suspect is a
juvenile or an adult doesn't really
matter for the purposes of this because
there is no pii associated with it it's
an instance of a hate crime and so where
normally if if in an adult situation we
may release the arrese name and data and
information relative to that we wouldn't
release the juveniles now nothing would
change relative to this we still
wouldn't do that but this is not really
what this is speaking to it's it's
generalizing the data I guess to see
what's happening right so
hopefully that answers the question but
I may be more follow
up so an example is a call for criminal
mischief on property it's a swas sticker
that's been spray painted is that going
to be coded as a hate crime or is it
going to be coded strictly as aival
Mischief call it's going to be coted as
a hate crime currently yep okay thank
you represent
Muse just wanted to to know if you you
could elaborate on what you mean by a
tally so so for instance when you say
that a tally is publicly available is
that something like just the the number
of hate crimes it's it's an indications
in the reporting of that event that
there is some bias motivation okay so
it's it's fairly generic at the moment
meaning it's determined somewhere in the
investigation and so you know the
example that representative Stone gave
certainly a smashed mailbox with no
indication that it involves some bias is
just that criminal mischief criminal
mischief that clearly has an indicator
like an Insignia that that's offensive
um is going to be reported as that and
so current data Gathering is is whether
or not it's present it's a yes no type
answer you know is is this investigation
or is this crime um or part of
it motivated by some bias yes or no I
mean so it's it's kind of that generic I
guess at the moment so that's where the
tally comes from and that's broken down
by a fence for us and we can break it
down by a few other things location and
County and and whatnot but it's I guess
it's sort of that simple at the moment
to say now relative to the bill we
obviously in the confines of that
investigation have who the suspect is
who the victim is and several other
factors that this this bill speaks to in
and putting that picture together a
little better but at the moment it's is
this crime bias motivated if so by what
bias one of the six or seven that that I
presented follow Muse followup
yeah
so I understand that there are there's
probably more data that is available uh
behind the scenes that you're not
putting up in the public tally
um would it be possible using the data
that you collect now um to do something
like um uh in in addition to Simply
talling up tallying up the uh the uh the
number of incidents to be able to
describe uh for instance uh where the
communities where these incidents are
taking place or the counties where these
incidents are taking place um which
groups um have been uh you know how
group different groups are are being
targeted by these incidents in a way
that it would actually like let's say
let somebody a member of the public be
able to look at a particular town or
Community to get an idea or are more
hate crimes Happening Here than in other
places certainly yeah I think we we can
do that um with what we currently
capture and the and the way that it's
being captured sort of behind the scenes
so to say the extent by which we can
break that down in how many different
ways I I can't answer that but I I think
we have some room to be able to paint a
um clearer picture with what we are
capturing and what our current
capabilities are thank
you representative
Balden are there any downsides to this
bill I think the only thing that I kind
of noticed is
um as I was reading through it in on
line 15 it says the of the suspects and
as long as unknown is okay for the
purposes of the bill that that might be
sufficient and I say that because
currently according to FBI ucci ners
reporting um race is only required for
arrests and so if we're getting into
reporting the race of suspects who in
theory have yet to have been arrested
for something
that how do we capture that are we
mandated to to capture that because we
believe it's a hate crime and for the
purposes of this bill we we should be
asking those questions is it based upon
the law enforcement's perception or is
it based upon the uh the involved
participants their their self-report of
that information and so not so much a
downfall I guess but a point of clarity
for the bill to say um that's one of
those difficult subject I guess it
depends on the intent um I I think it
may have more value if it's based upon
for the purposes of of the overall
intent if it's based upon the perception
of the officer but I know that that's a
difficult topic also because we don't
want to make that wrong we don't we
don't want to have that information be
inaccurate or incorrect and so that I
guess causes pause and and and not so
much concern but just an
observation um the only other concern
that I have is the format you know in
which
um this bill would expect us and I guess
I say us the department of safety to be
able to convey this information to the
Attorney General's office only because
we are the aggregator of that on a
Statewide basis we had a point of
contact for the FBI uh Uniform Crime
reporting U program and we administer
that program and so we spend a lot of
time every year um helping the local
departments ensure the accuracy and
timely submission of their data and so
um
I
think making sure that the way that
we're reporting that or able to report
that to the Attorney General's office um
is is in
a an easy format in a format that's
consistent with how we're currently
Gathering it and the ability for us to
break that down otherwise there may be
some additional expenses if we have to
reconfigure the current platform in
order to correctly report out the way
the the bill would would um request the
only other thing that I'm surprised
there and maybe there is a local um
Department here that's going to testify
to this but certainly having them post
this information on their website I have
to presume is going to come at some cost
um you know how that gets presented when
that gets presented um things like that
um certainly for us I mean we have a
website so we would certainly fall into
that and I guess I don't have an answer
to that um I assume we we have a Web
Master if you will on standby on salary
or what have you that probably wouldn't
necessarily cost us anything directly
but um I guess the logistics or the
practical application there's some not
concerns but
just
considerations thank you representative
Newman I have a question about um I
tried to find a definition of hate
crimes and could not find one in the law
but it it took me to the the uh part of
the law that was ex you talked about
extended sentences but then later you
said that that that if there is an ARR
if there is not an arrest if you don't
arrest someone for the crime it's just
reported do you have any information at
all that that is provided to the
attorney general so the Attorney General
could make a decision about whether
something like that ought to be
reported I'm not sure I like that we're
giving the Attorney General's office now
no I'm just saying that the the bill as
it's written G
says to the attorney general will make
the determination what needs to be
reported so so he would have to know
what kind of information is available
correct and my question is what do you
have any kind of information that's
available if arrest if an arrest is not
made or or yes because the crime itself
is still reported and again the way it's
the current reporting reporting process
is happening is if the investigating
agency feels feels that the crime is
motivated by some bias even though an
arrest is not made that case is flagged
with a yes meaning that's one of our
numbers in the tally and it's broken
down further by Will which of those
biases is it and so the the arrest is I
guess kind of Irrelevant for the
purposes of reporting my comment was
relative to the capturing the race of
suspects so if I simply have a suspect
and I can't prove or feel like I can't
bring the case forward and prosecute it
it still technically would be a
reportable hate crime in my opinion and
definition based upon the bill but so I
I don't know if I might up that that
does clarify everything I just wanted to
make sure because excuse me just follow
up and and so a race crime is typically
the list that's in that is in the uh
enhanced penalty the the normal list
that goes along with that correct thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you uh chair calls Grace
Murray um thank you for hearing my
testimony uh my name is Grace Murray and
I'm from Amhurst New Hampshire uh I'm
I'm here on behalf of New Hampshire
youth movement to ask ask that you
support hb1
1462 in my opinion we should be doing
everything we can to stop hate crimes
and I think the very least we could be
doing is reporting them properly and in
a way that can limit the amount that
they
happen um I'm here to make uh just three
brief points um so I'll keep it short um
number one I think people need to make
informed decisions about where they're
moving and where they're living and I
think that this data is actually
extremely important to that
um number two we need young people in
our state and this is an issue that is
important to young people and if we want
to keep young people in our state I
think it's important we listen to the
issues that they care
about and number three we need data to
make good personal choices in good
legislation and I think it's impossible
for us to expect you as our state
legislators to meet good legislation if
you don't have the data um and if you
don't have all the facts to support
that by knowledging that hate crimes um
by by acknowledging crimes motivated by
hatred of a certain people groups or
identities exist and by not reporting
them properly um it can feel like The
Stance being taken is that this
community doesn't need to be heard um or
that they don't matter supporting this
legislation is a good first step in
rectifying that um thank you and I can
take any questions if there are
any see no questions thank you for your
testimony today thank
you
the chair calls Liam
Megan hello my name is Liam Manan I'm
currently a resident of conquered and
I'm here speaking today as the general
manager of a business that has been
targeted by hate crime activity numerous
times in the last 18 months and as a
queer transgender man who's lived in New
Hampshire for my whole life um I'm sure
many of you have probably heard about
the incident took place on Father's Day
in 2023 outside of T Toler if you
haven't um I'll be brief a known hate
group neonazis from ns13 one targeted
our shop because of drag Story Time
which we host once a month um they
stormed the alley they were banging on
the Windows they were hailing Hitler the
whole thing um this not the only
incident that has happened at my place
of work in November the proud boys uh
protested the first story hour we hosted
at the new Cafe um in March of 2023 an
incendiary device was placed in the
planners outside of the shop and set off
during a drag show in April of 203 a
flyer circulated insinuating a summer of
Vengeance against T Toler because we
have storytime and drag shows for all
ages and in December of 23 a few days
after the AG announced their
investigation of the incident in June um
a couple of men got into the story time
and were disruptive and we suspect they
may be affiliated with what happened
before um and just a few weeks ago at
our first story of 2024 the same men
were actively outside um who had
Disturbed the previous event so I'm sure
that some of you have heard of the big
ones but there are smaller things that
happen and so I think all of us here can
agree on one thing whether we're
straight queer cisgender transgender
black Asian white immigrant citizen Etc
we all want to live in a space that's
safe and we don't have to fear violence
and we want a safe place for our
children to grow up a safe place for our
friends and family to gather and I think
having a database like this that's more
accessible to the public like uh Grace
was saying it's like to make informed
decisions about where to move where to
work where to go and spend time um I
think that's really important and I
think everybody living in New Hampshire
should should be able to have more
transparent information and versus just
a tally you know the way it is now most
people aren't going to understand you
know we all just had to ask him a bunch
of questions to understand how the
current system works Al I think having a
slightly more broken down and easier
thing to understand for the the lay
person is essential um New Hampshire has
a hate problem and I believe that uh
this is a first step towards solving
that problem and so please support this
bill and I'm happy to take any
questions representative
scitec hav't they gotten tired you think
so you really would think
so thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
testify this bill was not done so seeing
none Clos public hearing with that I
open the public hearing on House Bill
152 and invite sponsor to introduce the
bill
chairman Roy members of the committee my
name is Le bney and I represent Grafton
District 11 thank you for the
opportunity to introduce hb52 relative
to alcohol rated offenses and
prohibitions this bill came about after
the police chief in my town received
complaints of beer cans regularly
appearing on the side of the road in
specific areas of town while
investigating these incidents it was
determined that the prevailing reason
people litter in this way is to avoid
the open container law laws prohibiting
open containers do not prevent people
from having alcohol in the vehicle but
they do create a very strong incentive
to toss containers on the side of the
road to avoid enforcement and penalties
thus forming the impetus for this
bill 10 other states have some form of
allowance on open alcohol containers
Alaska Arkansas Connecticut Delaware
Louisiana Mississippi Missouri Virginia
Tennessee and West Virginia one thing
many of these states have in common with
New Hampshire is that tourism is a major
component of their economy the argument
on economic terms is simple allowing
open alcohol containers and vehicles
contributes to more alcohol consumption
and therefore more
Revenue while the original idea for the
bill was just to repeal prohibition on
open containers we felt that a repeal
should include alternative tools for law
enforcement to take drunk drivers off
the
road Parts one and two of the bill allow
police officer upon already establishing
reasonable articulable suspicion that a
driver of a vehicle may be under the
influence to require the driver to
submit to a horizontal gaze and stigmus
test the result of which could then be
used to establish probable cost for
further action a horizontal gaze a
stigmus test does not require the driver
to exit the vehicle and is relatively
simple to perform performing the test
also provides more opportunities for the
officer to interact with the driver and
ascertain sobriety
in summary open container prohibition
creates an incentive to litter while
removing the prohibition could have
positive economic impact on tourism and
to combat negative effects of repealing
the prohibition this bill includes an
extra tool for police to assess drivers
that may be impaired I'm open to working
with the committee on any amendments to
particularly for parts one and two of
the bill to reduce any possible Fourth
Amendment concerns but also part three
if the committee feels some restriction
should remain related to open container
ERS thank you and I'll take any
questions representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm care what
we're talking about is kind of trying to
guide Behavior right um if you're saying
that people are more likely to throw uh
their container out so that an officer
does not see it because this law is this
way we're trying to encourage behavior
and I guess my question is wouldn't
being pulled over over with an open
container in your car also encourage the
officer to detain you and uh and to to
be more likely um to go through that
process of testing you and all that kind
of stuff doesn't that kind
of I'm just wondering about if we're
encouraging behavior wouldn't that also
encourage people to want to throw the
container out because they don't want to
be tested in that way uh thank you for
the question if I understand correctly
so uh an open container could be in the
back seat right it could be somebody in
the back seat that's drinking not
necessarily the driver so just kind of
going by you know first principles
thinking if if the goal is to prevent a
drunk driver right that's that's the
whole reason for all of these laws is to
prevent a a driver behind the wheel of
being drunk um then an open container
law is kind of aside you know you're
hoping that there's a correlation
between an open container in the vehicle
or or disallow prohibiting open
container would also prevent drunk
drivers but it's not you know it's not
one and the same right you can have an
open container and it couldn't it could
be somebody else drinking in the vehicle
the passenger in the back for example
and not the driver can I follow up
quickly um thank you for that
clarification um
um is the is the premise that someone
would have a a half a bottle of wine in
um a bag in their back seat and if they
were um thinking that they were going to
be pulled over they would reach into the
back of the car and throw that out and
that's the problem that that we're
trying to
address uh so I mean that that's
certainly possible the specific issue
that we had in Grafton is that people
would well people would throw mostly
empty containers right so they would be
drinking a beer while you know in the
vehicle and then they would just toss it
out so there wouldn't be anything in the
car afterwards okay thank
you repr s thank you and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm just looking up the details of
how this test works because that was
something I was unfamiliar with it seems
very similar to the test that is used
often to determine if people have the
ability to track their Vision accurately
regardless of use of alcohol but just
people who have Vision issues um is
there a way for someone uh to know
whether it's someone who's under the
influence versus someone who simply has
visual tracking problems based on what's
in here thank you thank you for that
question so uh the police already do
that test the difference is uh they can
they have to ask the driver um and and
the driver can refuse unless they had
probable cause right unless they smell
alcohol or there's other obvious signs
that they're they're impaired um this
would allow them to do the same test
following the same procedure but uh with
a lighter um it would be articulable
suspicion so for example you're driving
be a police driving behind somebody and
they're you know swerving on the road
now the swerving could be because
they're playing on their phone or kids
are in the back or something like that
right not necessarily they're under the
influence um so it it allows them but
they but they have a suspicion that
something's going on so it would allow
them to to require to do that test as
opposed to currently where you have to
have uh probable cause right they have
to either smell alcohol see somebody
drinking or or something like that thank
you thank you
um no further questions thank you thank
you um chair calls Captain
Muzzy Captain muzy did you sign up for
this the chair recognizes Lieutenant
storm
thank you uh my name is uh Lieutenant
Chris storm I am uh from the Department
of Safety Division of State Police I am
currently the highway safety liaison for
the State Police I am also the state's
field sobriety coordinator for the whole
state as far and I can uh answer uh
representative celik's question that she
had prior to that um first and foremost
um the department of safety is opposing
this bill and I I'll just read you some
few notes that uh that I put down uh
first of all we'd like to thank them for
um supporting law enforcement in uh
trying to uh reduce the number of uh
DWIs that we have on our our roadways uh
I would like to point out our concerns
with the potential implications of
suspending individuals um for just
refusing horizontal gaze in stagos on uh
the side of the road it's important to
note that the refusal of hdn test alone
should not be the sole reason for
suspending someone's license um there
are various factors that should be taken
into consideration when determining the
administrative license suspension it's
essential for law enforcement to
consider totality of the circumstances
and utilize a combination of tests and
observations to make it fair impartial
and accurate assessment of someone's
impairment although hgn is an excellent
um test for deterring um detecting
impairment it's also important for law
enforcement to conduct all standardized
field sobriety tests just conducting
horizontal gaze and Status does not
provide comprehensive assessment of that
particular individual's
impairment different individuals may
exhibit varying signs of impairment and
relying solely on one test may not
provide a complete picture of their
condition by conducting multiple field
sobriety test law enforcement can gather
accurate and reliable evidence to
determine whether an individual is under
the influence of alcohol or drugs this
approach helps to ensure that law
enforcement makes informed decision and
help upholds fairness and accuracy in
their assessments conducting all field
sobriety test should also help minimize
the potential of Errors of that
particular law enforcement officer it is
also very important to note that not all
drug categories cause hdn if law
enforcement doesn't do all the fields of
bar is possible to miss that particular
um individual that may be under the
influence of
drugs um this bill um makes it clear
that um open container is also an
allowable thing um we oppose that for uh
numerous um reasons one we don't want um
open alcohol containers with that that
that potential for any operator actually
drink um alcohol while operating a
vehicle that then may uh lead to
impairment as uh as they travel down our
roadways
um this bill makes it clear um to take
um impair that um representative takes
impaired driving um very seriously um
but we need to address the refusal of
implied consent as a whole in New
Hampshire as we are one of the worst
states in the country as far as refusals
go um there's currently a bill um Senate
Bill 418 that was within um the Senate
um that should be coming over here to
the house that addresses many of the
issues that we're already very concerned
about as far as the refusals go so we
ask that um
you uh support that bill um I will take
any questions as far as uh field
sobriety as far as uh hgn goes or the
open
container thank you lieutenant currently
if you refuse the breathalyzer your
license is suspended is that correct
that is correct sir but if you refuse
the field sobriety there's no
consequence that's a First Amendment
issue is that correct so yes and no so
on the side of the road you are correct
um there is no penalty for refusing
anything upon the side of the road but
the implied consent in that informed
piece that we would have to then do on
the side of the road also makes it very
complicated and very convoluted that we
would have to inform somebody that they
are required to do this but then
continue on with other standardized
field sobriety tests on the roadway so
that would be very confusing especially
if that individual is under the
influence of something would make it
very confusing gotcha um with regard to
the horizontal gaze and nagas and
frankly the other test as well is it not
common practice to ask first do you have
any medical conditions that would
prohibit you from um performing
successfully on these tests yeah so New
Hampshire we actually have um a Supreme
Court case called state to First the
hood and all police officers here in New
Hampshire are trained under the
standardized field sobriety testing um
battery which is conducted by the
national highway traffic safety
administration and that Supreme Court
law says that we need to inform people
and do everything exactly the way that
we were trained on the side uh for those
individuals on the side of the road so
the answer to your question is yes there
is a medical um questioning that happens
prior to administering standardized
field sobriety and lastly for me um I
Heard the sponsor say that you could
perform the horizontal Gaze on the
stagis test while the operator was
seated the vehicle is that that's
correct um so that the head has to be
aligned with the body to do that
perfectly so it would be very difficult
if that operator was turning to the left
and their head was not exactly in line
with the body because you can actually
induce something called pan Which is
positional alcohol and the stagna so
they could actually increase what that
individual looks like or actually
decrease what you're actually seeing
depending on the particular individual
that would cause the accuracy of the
test to be thrown out the window yes if
their head is not in line with the body
it absolutely is in accurate test thank
you further questions for the lieutenant
representative s it's perfectly legal
for me to drink a Coke while I'm driving
right certainly is why can't I have a
Budweiser while I'm driving if I'm under
008 and not impaired well if you're not
impaired that's fine but the the the
problem with drinking in driving is each
individual metabolizes alcohol
differently right you could be
increasing um as you continue to drink
and as you go as time goes on while you
have that open container you're
consuming alcohol your blood alcohol
obviously the more you consume the
higher it's going
up I would also answer that question
because I would say because we said so
Representative no thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question just
really quickly if if I were pulled over
and I had uh and my passenger had an
open Budweiser or something would you be
more or less likely to test me uh and be
suspicious of me uh driving into the
influence so that's a great question so
twofold once obviously we'd smell the
odor of alcoholic beverage coming from
that vehicle right so it's very hard to
determine exactly who that particular um
that particular odor is coming from so
we would have to do some work we'd have
to ask some questioning and we'd have to
start by asking probably that individual
step from the vehicle if they'd be
willing to conduct field sobriety test
okay thank you
Lieutenant is open contained an
arrestable
offense so obviously everything's an
arrestable offense but nor normally we
would just uh issue that individual a
citation okay so how often in your
experience do you run across people with
a bunch of empty beer cans all over the
back seat floor um that does not result
in an arrest is it quite often quite
it's more normal that you don't arrest
for that offense unless you have an oui
with it is that yes sir thank you
see no further questions thank you oh
did you
have okay who did you point
out question no all right thank
you sure absolutely
um any other people wishing to testify
on this bill who have not testified on a
bill seeing none I hereby close the
public hearing on House Bill 1
and that concludes our business for
today representative scitec wanted to
say something I may address the
committee and the lieutenant in
1991 uh I know the representative who
spoke against open container and he lost
to Karen Wadsworth before she was a
clerk she was a rep from Lebanon I up
that way not Lebanon anyway uh I made
that point then I make it again it's I
want to support law enforcement but it
just seems over the top I could be a
passenger drinking my bud and you're
it's still I've said enough thank
you did you just say that that you are
going to lose your re-election bit I'm
not sure what you
said
hello Court
out
e
iiz um representative scitec to make a
motion I'm going to move that we that
this bill be recommended as
itl I'll second uh 1502 and seconded by
representative here GA would you like to
speak to your motion representative site
yes uh what we heard uh was that this
was ostensibly a litter uh protection uh
bill that's not the right word uh to
prevent litter from people who are
avoiding the
um open container prohibition we've in
the testimony from the state police we
heard that uh there is a practical
problem in administering this test
because you have to have uh the proper
alignment uh in order that the this uh I
test I can't pronounce it at the moment
uh be effective and accurate there are
also constitutional problems in stopping
somebody without
in initiating this kind of test without
probable cause and for that reason this
bill would require uh may not even be
may not even be able to be saved with an
amendment uh the with respect to the
open container portion of the bill it's
really uh the the this is would be
flogging a dead course it's already
failed in our in my view our view I will
hope in The committee's View on the
grounds that I've just talked about so
that's my uh statement thank you
representative gath would you like to
speak to your second yes um I agree with
everything that um the representative um
produced um it says here that
um what I liked about it was that he
said that this was not a complete
approach to the situation so um but he
also mentioned that they have a bill
that they would like us to look at um
that's coming from the Senate that seems
to be more
complete 1418 thank you any further
discussion being none I'd ask clerk to
call the RO motion of floor is
inexpedient to legislate for House Bill
152 Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative
pu yes representative jandrin or sorry
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Harriet gther yes representative Muse
yes representative bden yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sake yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy chair Vols
170 170 unanimous inexpedient to
legislate any objection to consent
seeing none it will go on consent House
Bill 1 152 is hereby closed um we'll see
you all on
Monday anyone cannot be here on Monday
please talk to your um to your leader or
to representative roads so we can get
replacements for
everybody